Four,
three,
two,
one.
What's up ma?
What's up buddy?
Good to see you,
man.
It's good to see you.
I'm glad we decided to get together and
do this,
you know,
and talk and um,
it's all crazy subject,
right?
I mean you and I have known each other
for since 2012 when I did meet eater.
You were there filming when I shot my
first deer,
which is very important part of my life
man.
And then you went on to direct and
produce parts unknown with our late
friend Anthony Bourdain and we started
probably be a good thing to come in here
and just talk.
Talk about them.
Yeah man.
And uh,
and I'm really grateful for it,
you know,
it's actually,
a lot of people
have been saying to me like,
oh,
it must be really hard to talk about
that.
It must really,
it's.
I actually find it kind of the opposite.
Like I want to talk about him.
I want to talk about who he was and what
that experience was,
you know.
So,
um,
thanks ma'am.
My pleasure brother.
Did you,
did you know him before you guys started
working together?
No,
no.
I met Tony a 10 years ago and I was
called in.
He had a DP on a show who at the last
minute canceled,
couldn't go to Egypt.
So,
uh,
I got a call like a week before,
you know,
it's like,
do you want to go to Egypt with Anthony
Bourdain was like,
you're fucking absolutely.
Um,
and uh,
and so I met him in Cairo,
man,
like kind of like perfect.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That's like Indiana Jones.
Exactly.
Man episode when you guys ate a camel.
No,
no,
we didn't need a camel.
No,
but,
um,
you know,
uh,
I met him there,
you know,
we start filming,
we're on the streets of Cairo and like,
you know,
like all of a sudden is thrown into
these kitchens.
We were eating pigeon,
you know,
it's like go in,
cover them cooking pigeon.
And I'd seen the show like maybe once
before,
but I knew who he was and I knew what
that adventure was,
you know,
and I was so amped for it.
Um,
and then there was this seminal moment
on that show where we go out and we'd go
ripping across the desert with the
Bedouin and go out and cook a goat,
a in the ground,
you know.
Um,
and so as we're driving out over the
desert,
we're like,
well,
we need to,
we need some shots from car to car.
Right.
And I was like,
Oh,
get on the roof,
you know,
and uh,
and there's like this for,
for some reason there's a four post bed
tied to the roof of this land rover.
And so I get up there and kind of like,
you know,
latch my arm around it and these guys
take off at I,
I swear,
80 miles an hour across the desert and
you're on a bed.
Absolutely,
absolutely no regard for the fact that
like,
I'm on the roof,
you know,
I'm shooting.
And,
and when we got there we got to camp.
I survived it.
I'm at this big black and blue where I
was holding onto the four post bed and I
go over and I show Tony and um,
that was it man.
From that moment on,
he was like,
I liked this guy and I started going out
with him,
you know,
I started getting invited to do more
shows.
So that was good.
How many years?
Ten years.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
I didn't realize that parts unknown was
even an oil.
Well,
you doing no reservations.
Yeah.
So that was a no reservation show and
then we went to parts unknown five years
ago.
Wow.
Yeah.
So parts of one has been on for five
years
and that uh,
you know,
that transition.
No,
no reservation was great and it really
laid the foundation for what we do and
what Tony did.
I think it really built an audience and
a following for him and that's where I
found out about it.
Right,
exactly.
It was a great show,
you know?
Um,
but that,
like that transition going on to CNN,
going into parts unknown,
that really,
that really changed things have really
opened up a lot of locations and stuff
that we didn't have access to before.
It opened up,
you know,
kind of CNNS logistics,
a Rolodex and you know,
things that we didn't have at the other
network,
you know.
And uh,
and so that's,
you know,
no reservations was awesome.
We did some incredible shows.
Parts unknown is where it got really
fun.
Yeah.
That was on another level.
I remember watching the chains.
I'm like,
okay,
this is more more him,
you know,
to everything from the opening music to
the tone of it and the narration.
Yeah,
for sure.
And then in,
you know,
you've got to hand it to CNN to is like
all of a sudden we had these creative
partners who were like willing to let
him be him,
you know,
like willing to let him do a show like
the Tokyo show.
We're like,
you know,
really climbing into Japanese subculture
is rope bondage,
tentacle porn,
you know,
all this stuff that most network
executives,
they're probably a little bit leery of.
CNN was Kinda like,
you know,
go for it man.
Be Yourself,
you know,
and let's figure out what this is
together.
You know,
that's amazing.
That really is amazing.
And with one of the things that really
made that show was Tony's narration
because the narration gave you a sense
of the way his,
his sort of passionate enthusiasm for
the world and for various aspects of
cooking and travel and food and culture.
Like you got it through his own words,
you know?
Yeah.
I think that's,
I mean maybe in some ways the most
important aspect of the show.
Uh,
you know,
I mean he is after all a writer,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
and I'm in that is how he experienced
the world.
Um,
but actually making the shows and the
technical part of actually making the
shows,
you know,
we'd once you go through and kind of
edit the and you know,
none of that voiceover was in at the
rough cut phase and then you send it out
to him and get his writing back and
record that.
Vo and I keep describing it is like that
kind of Dr. Frankenstein lightening bolt
to the temples kind of moment where like
the monster rises,
it would really bring the show to life.
So this kinda carcass that was laid out
in rough cut form on the table,
all of a sudden just gasped and jumped
up and,
you know,
it was really beautiful to see that and
to have,
you know,
as a director,
as a producer,
as a creative,
you know,
at any level,
to have that kind of power to have his
voice and his writing and his
introspection and thoughts and you know,
um,
that would have like powerful,
powerful force to work with.
Well,
it was a brilliant design.
The way the show is put together,
that narration really did make it
something special and different from all
those other kinds of shows because it
just his articulate and insightful and
poetic and artistic view of these things
that he had this infectious passion for
things.
He completely changed the way I thought
about cooking.
I had always thought about cooking as,
oh,
this guy knows how to make delicious
food.
Oh,
this place has good ribs is.
And then when I saw his show,
when I saw parts unknown,
I went,
oh,
it's an art form.
It's just an art form that you eat.
Absolutely contemporary art form.
Yeah,
and even beyond that,
it's an art form that's in that taking
and incorporating all of these greater
kind of macro social elements of,
you know,
where you are,
the history of where you are,
you know,
what people did for a living,
what people's ancestors did for a
living,
you know,
it.
Um,
it's rooted in so much more than what I
think,
you know,
ultimately it feels like we kind of joke
around a lot and say like,
yeah,
it's the food shows,
not a food show,
you know,
but the reason that worked I think is
because of what you're saying and you
know,
the food food is an art form that
incorporates all of these other aspects.
And so it can be a jumping point off for
exploration into anything you want to
talk about.
I'm to talk to about the history of a
place,
the politics of a place,
you know,
uh,
the religion of a place,
you know,
all of these things that inform who
people are.
Well that's all written into the cuisine
of a place or an area.
Yeah.
And,
and he was into stuff that wasn't
necessarily even like high,
you know,
high dollar items.
He was into like street food.
Definitely.
Yeah.
It wasn't just the finest French know
trolls where these celebrated world
famous chefs were cooking these bizarre
small plate sort of masterpieces.
No,
he would love street tacos.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
again,
I think that kind of like a whole new
fresh take on looking at food,
you know,
it's like,
it's easy to,
you know,
to look at these kind of high end French
preparations is highly talented,
highly trained French chefs.
Um,
and there's,
there's tremendous beauty in that and
all of those other things we've talked
about.
But to look at the woman on the corner,
you know,
the making,
uh,
you know,
the best,
Lingua Tacos,
that was revolutionary.
And then the realization that all of
that,
all of that greatness,
all of that nuance,
all of that flavor,
you know,
um,
contained right within there,
that was an access point to it as well.
It's just an access point that everyone
can afford that everyone can go and,
and uh,
you know,
I mean,
right place at the right time.
I think that people like,
it seems like the culture at large was
ready for that,
like experience in food and ready to
kind of chase that because now that's,
that's all anyone wants now.
Well,
I think it's because of him.
I really do.
I really do because I'm sure that he
changed the way I look at things for
terms of food and I think he had that
effect on many people may think about
how many years was known for five and
then no reservations for nine new
reservations.
Yeah,
for about 10.
And then there was a cook's tour before
that,
so original all told a decade and a half
of his influence on people's food
choices and just appreciation for food.
I mean,
I know personally I've had some great
meals in restaurants,
but some of my favorite meals had been
like stepping outside of a bar,
you know,
it's 1:30,
you got a little buzz on and some dudes
got a Taco truck and like,
oh baby,
what do you got over there?
And my friend or in New York,
you know,
it's late at night and there's a falafel
cart.
And some guys got a incredible kabobs.
Like,
oh,
something about street food man.
Absolutely man.
And yeah,
I kinda keep like a,
like a loose running list of my favorite
meals,
you know,
and um,
and some of them are on the show and
some of them are not on the show.
And I'd say most of them are that,
you know,
most of them are accidentally stumbling
into someplace where someone's doing
something completely awesome that isn't,
you know,
some massive 26 course tasting menu.
Um,
and I think it's also about,
you know,
it's about place,
it's about where you are,
the context of where you're getting,
what it smells like,
what it sounds like,
what it looks like,
you know.
Um,
who you're with,
you know,
and uh,
and so,
you know,
that's Kinda,
I think another reason to show kind of
worked is we had an opportunity to
architect or articulate all of those,
all of those elements,
you know,
are able to choose an incredibly
interesting guests to sit down with it,
a really interesting restaurant with,
you know,
cooking over
a really interesting backstory in a
beautiful place and uh,
and then use the power of kind of the
magic of TV to,
you know,
to Polish it up and present this version
of travel and food in the world that,
you know,
really everywhere too.
I mean,
you guys covered Asia,
you covered Europe,
you covered some weird places in the
south where people are cooking pigs in
their backyard.
I mean,
it was just,
it,
it gave people an understanding of the
preparation of food and a view to chefs
and this view of chefs as artists.
I mean these chefs look like tattoo
artists.
They look like,
you know,
guys who are painters or something,
or women who are sculptors.
I mean,
they're,
they're real similar in the way they,
they appear to what we consider artists.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And I,
and I think too,
I mean,
I,
you know,
what I kind of love about like,
at this point,
spent a good amount of time in kitchens
and good around Mount of time around
kitchen staff is there's kind of two
elements coming together.
There's,
there's the,
the artistic element that you're talking
about,
right?
But there's also this very,
you know,
very earnest working class kind of
element to the way a kitchen works,
you know,
it was tough,
hard,
sweaty work,
you know,
it's a rough environment,
and I,
and I think that's kind of part of what
makes it so appealing to us.
He kind of pulled back the curtain on,
on that,
you know,
let's say like these guys are,
these guys are not these inaccessible
icons though.
Paul bocuse of the world,
you know,
they are um,
as much as Paul bocuse is awesome,
you know,
they are these kind of rough and tumble,
guys that are back there making
something really awesome.
Tony also had this sort of punk rock
sensibility to it all to you know,
mean that was part of the thing about
him that people found appealing is that
they had seen cooking shows before,
but they never saw cooking shows where
the host gets fucked up.
No,
dude,
I was first time I partnered with him,
I'm like,
this guy goes so hard.
I was amazing.
Told me about it.
It was amazing.
I was like,
I can't believe he can do this all the
time.
Like I think one of them
first times we ever got hung out
together was in Montreal.
We were there for UFC fights and we went
out afterwards and got.
We had some steaks and it was just
amazing walking into this restaurant and
people freaking out.
One guy actually had a copy of kitchen
confidential in the actual kitchen
itself and had tony sign it.
It was pretty fun.
A fucking
bad ass.
Where'd you go?
You do not remember Joe Beef?
No,
it wasn't,
but he turned me on a job and eaten
there several times since then.
Those guys are coming on the podcast to
fred and Dave now.
They're fucking amazing.
That restaurant is one of my favorite
restaurants on the planet.
No doubt they'll hurt you.
They keep it coming for sure.
Give you an inch thick slab
of flog raw.
Yes.
Well
show.
One of the ones that I really loved was
the one where they did ice fishing there
were on the water and they had this ice
fishing shack,
but inside the ice fishing shack they
had find silverware and find China and
they had bottles of really excellent
wine and they were cooking on a wood
stove.
They had a wood stove and they were
cooking fog while right,
right there on the stove and then they
were laying out what they think makes
you a good dinner companion.
And David's like,
I shut my phone off.
I turned it off.
I put it away and he goes,
I don't check it,
don't.
He goes,
I don't put my elbows on the table,
you know?
And he's like,
can I come prepared with stories?
And Tony was like,
you prepare your stories.
I have stories to tell.
I come prepared like to him it's like
not really a performance,
but it's an agreement that you're going
to,
you're going to go there and you're
going to share this enthusiasm for this
experience together and you're going to
try to enhance it with your own
anecdotes and personality and your own
appreciation for the food and the wine
and then afterwards they're smoking
Cuban cigars.
It was like the whole things it made you
want to go eat at a really good place.
Yeah.
Or in a,
in a,
in a shack on a frozen lake with,
with people who understand that there's
an elegance to all of these things,
you know,
that you can create an environment that,
that has an elegance.
And that's,
you know,
I'd say that's like a hallmark of a lot
of the chefs that I've met through the
show is like,
you will see that no matter how big they
get,
no matter how successful there is an
inherent kind of desire to please on
multiple levels.
You know,
you'll have,
like I remember we were in a Daniel
Boulud's house in France or did his
parents house.
Right?
And so he,
Daniel Ballou like the mega chef,
you know,
um,
but like running around to all of the
crew members,
like you have something to eat,
are you good?
Do you want another glass of wine?
Do you want to look,
you know,
and it just inherited his nature is
exactly what you're talking about.
This idea that,
you know,
they have this just
ongoing desire to please their guests,
to entertain,
to,
you know,
make sure that everyone's taken care of
the curators,
have an experience.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
You know.
And so to be able to,
you know,
run around the world for 10 years and
explore.
That was nice man.
Man.
I can only imagine.
How many shows did you guys film
together?
I don't,
you know,
I dunno.
Fifty seven or 60,
something like that.
Somewhere in La.
Yeah.
Wow.
So I mean listen,
there are people,
you know,
at 10 years on the show,
I was on the show for a long time.
There's people lot longer.
There's people that did the whole 17
years.
People have done well over $100,
you know,
no one left that
show.
You don't leave that show if you get a
spot on it.
Were you with him when,
when it ended?
No.
Uh,
no.
I was with him,
um,
about a week and a half before.
Uh,
so now I had good friends that were
there.
I was in Chicago and uh,
I've woke up and checked my phone and I
got a text from my friend Maynard
Maynard Keenan
from tool and um,
maynard is a Jujitsu brown belt and
really loves Jujitsu.
Any,
any,
um,
texted me.
He said so much for the uh,
maynard versus Anthony Bordain celebrity
Jujitsu match
and that's the whole text
and um,
you know,
just sunk,
sunk a pit in my stomach and I just
picked up my phone.
I went into Google and I looked it up
and I saw it.
I'm just like,
oh fuck.
I just couldn't believe it.
I couldn't believe it.
No.
Started crying
I think.
I think I called my wife.
They're called maynard.
I texted him,
I called my wife,
called a few friends,
you know,
just like,
just couldn't believe,
you know,
when someone's just not there anymore.
I didn't get to see him a lot,
but I was just,
uh,
just appreciated the fuck out of that
dude,
you know,
like,
I don't want to do anybody's TV show,
but when I got a call from him I was
like,
fuck yeah,
what are we going to do?
We're gonna shoot pheasants and,
and hunt and camp and we're going to
cook by the campfire.
Fuck them in,
dude,
you know,
I'm in.
I just really appreciated him as a
genuine,
unique person.
Like is it genuine,
rare person?
And uh,
you know,
that's,
that's what I got out of being.
Being able to spend some time with him
and being able to talk to him and pick
his brain.
And he did my podcast once and we always
planned on doing it again,
which we never got around to it because
we're both have ridiculous schedules.
But just my,
I would think about things differently
because of him.
Like my eye.
I would sometimes hold things to his
standards and he me like legitimately is
appreciation for things and his
enthusiasm for things changed the way I
look at a lot,
a lot of aspects of food and culture
and,
and even travel,
you know.
Yeah.
I mean I'm,
I'm sorry ma'am.
I and I,
and I know he thought very highly of you
and that was that experience in Montana
was fantastic,
man.
So fun.
Um,
okay.
You know,
it's been,
it's been a rough three months and it's
still hard for me to really
contextualize it and put it together.
It feels like,
you know,
upside down world,
like there's no.
And he was such a,
I mean it was a friend and a
collaborator,
you know,
but also just such an icon to me,
you know.
Um,
and uh,
did,
it's almost like,
you know,
it's almost like the sun disappears,
or something.
It's something that is so just
inherently part of life they're in and
dependable and you know.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean that's been all right.
It's hard to describe how,
how profound that span.
I remember when he got into Jujitsu,
I got psyched because I'm like,
we got more to talk about now I can
actually,
I can actually show them shit,
you know,
he was always asking about things,
he's really good at things.
Remember when we were in Montana,
we were rolling around on the dirt
shoulder stuff.
Him and Josh was like,
like,
when you're in here,
like here's what you can do,
you can get.
And he's like,
oh yeah.
He's like,
he was so a wide eyed,
you know,
I think it was before he even got his
blue belt or maybe it was like around
blue belt.
So he was super,
super jacked about it and he was doing
it every day.
I remember when we were,
we were filming,
we were outside of billings.
Is that where we were?
Where were we?
Yeah,
well we're,
the hunt was the hunt.
We were in like
go up in central Montana,
you know.
So,
um,
we kind of started in billings,
but we headed up towards central
Montana.
He was training so often and even on the
road that he traveled to a club,
there was just a Jujitsu club and
Bozeman.
Yeah,
and he found some guys and he was
rolling with these guys in Bozeman.
Definitely like,
damn,
you're doing it every day because that
was a day for a long time on the show.
That was a mandate and we find the
local,
you know,
the local clubs and make sure that he
had a place or role texted me from some
European bloc country.
Said he was shitting bone bone chips as
a.
He worked out with some old school
Carlson Gracie guys.
They don't believe in rolling light.
It's all top game and smashing you
shitting bone chips,
but I just,
I admired that a guy could be 58 years
old and decide I'm going to learn
Jujitsu and I'm going to be obsessed
with it.
And then he became addicted to it.
Which,
you know,
Jujitsu is a very beneficial thing to be
addicted to,
but it is absolutely an addiction.
I've,
I've come back from injuries were.
I definitely shouldn't have been
training yet and I just wrapped my arm
up and just fucking get in there.
People get super,
super addicted to it and he got addicted
to it.
Just like he's been addicted to many
things.
He,
he jumped right into the Jujitsu,
Jujitsu experience.
Yeah,
man,
I'm,
I'm glad he did.
It wasn't me.
Anyway,
it was clearly like really good for him
to us.
I mean,
I know very little about Jujitsu.
I know what I know from Tony,
you know,
slim.
Yeah.
He lost all that weight.
All of a sudden you had to stop spacs up
smoking,
you know,
those were,
those were big things,
man.
And uh,
and he looked great and he,
you know,
he got off statens.
You're no longer on any sort of
medication.
He lost all that weight to cut all the
carbs out.
It was just eating like crazy man.
He looked so good.
He did look good.
Um,
he did look good and also just,
I,
you know,
the whole thing was kind of indicative
of the way he.
I mean,
he did things so passionately,
you know,
whether it was travel the world and
soaking up all these experiences or
Jujitsu or whatever he was into
something.
If something caught his attention,
he was just so aggressive about
knowledge,
learning what he could,
pulling everything out of it that,
that he could,
you know,
it was crazy to see someone do something
that's that physically demanding 58 with
no background in athletics at all.
Yeah,
like you could see when he was like,
even when he was doing things,
like when he went to curt oce anders
place and was rolling around,
like he doesn't have a background in
that,
but he's just pushing himself to it.
Yeah.
And again,
I think that was true with everything,
you know,
I mean if he,
if it was something that was interesting
to him,
he just went,
you know,
he loved it,
man.
It was crazy.
And I said,
you know,
I remember texting him going like,
how deep you getting into it?
He goes,
real fucking deep end.
he goes,
I'm getting tapped out everyday.
But he goes,
I'm giving guys half my age of real
struggle,
and he goes,
uh,
and I'm loving it.
Yeah.
And he talked about that a lot.
I mean,
I think he talked about like the,
the failure as much as anything else.
I love that going in and,
you know,
getting smashed.
Yeah.
It,
you know,
again,
to his credit,
you know,
show up in these places,
Bozeman,
Montana,
man or,
or butte.
You know what I mean?
I think he rolled in Butte butte a hard
hit and town,
man,
listen,
I love beauty.
I love you too much respect to anyone
from butte.
But man,
that's a hard hit in town.
You know,
you'd roll into real cowboys,
you know,
and uh,
and get the shit kicked out of him and
show up on set all you know,
sore and bruised and oh man,
oh no.
And then just jump into that.
Know it's just different for a guy who's
58.
I mean you got a guy who does it at 20.
I admire anybody who does Jujitsu
because it's a real humbling ego
dissolving experience and a lot of ways
because she's makes you realize like all
your illusions of how well you can
defend yourself.
They go out the window and some just
chokes you easily and you're like,
oh great.
I'm just a pitch.
Wandered around running around this life
thinking I'm a man.
But the fact that he did it at 58 just
showed what kind of a unusual duty was.
Yeah.
But what you just talked about there.
I mean,
what you're talking about with like the
ego diminishing aspect of it.
Again,
I think that that was something that he
took great pleasure in and I think that,
you know,
if you look at the way he went through
the world,
I'm one of the things that,
you know,
I appreciate it right off the bat.
And one of the things that kept me
around as long as I stayed around,
you know,
um,
it was the fact that it took for Tony.
I think that he was constantly trying to
dismantle that persona.
You know,
to say like,
I'm,
I'm not the focal point of this scene,
what I'm the,
what we're interested in here,
what I'm interested in talking about is
out there.
That's the camera's pointed away from
me.
You know,
he was kind of a clearinghouse for all
that information and he was the root of
the show and it was his journey.
But,
you know,
ultimately,
what was refreshing is he wasn't like
working with some celebrity or hosts
that was completely consumed by their
own ego and their own,
you know,
brandon and how they were presented to
the world.
That's so disgusting,
right.
You know?
Yeah,
Dude.
But it's,
it's everywhere.
It's everywhere.
Yeah.
He was very self deprecating and,
and he had reverence for real artists
and real masters and that reverence came
across cross.
I texted him about some guy,
there was a photo of a restaurant and
uh,
I'm sure it's still on my phone,
subdued,
who's like a real famous guy who's like
some big time chef character and I was
eating in this restaurant.
And so I'm like,
who the fuck is this guy?
I guess it seems like it's a big deal.
And so,
uh,
I uh,
I texted him the photo.
This cat right here.
Yeah.
Do you guys was that guy's name?
So I said,
who is,
that guy says Marco Pierre White Made
Ramsey cry like a bitch all the time.
Original rockstar chef genius madman the
original punk.
But that kind of text,
like that's,
that's a Tony Bourdain texts.
Um,
and that's,
that's what that,
that text shows that reverence for the
master.
Oh yeah.
You know,
I mean even the way he phrases it,
you know,
made him cry like a bitch all the time.
Original rockstar chef genius madman
know.
And um,
and,
and that's the way it was.
What worked about that is he had a,
like an instant ability to sniff through
the bullshit,
you know,
so,
listen,
there's all kinds of famous people,
celebrities and well accomplished people
that he met that he didn't feel that
way.
Not,
you know,
he would cut through that shit
instantly,
but if you were on his radar in that
way,
you know,
it's like total commitment to what you
do.
You're in or you're out there.
You Got Anthony Bourdain.
Exactly.
Do you want to be in that list of people
is like,
that's a cool list of.
Yeah.
Well I just remember hanging out with
them,
you know,
like I just,
it was one of those
guys.
He was one of the ones that I met that I
was like pretty starstruck.
Like right away.
Yeah.
I said something really stupid,
like my wife says you're my boyfriend
because they watched actually show all
the time.
She would just joke around how you want
your boyfriend on TV.
Like great.
Skype is great,
but I'm like,
uh,
when we were in Montana,
that's when I really.
Well I always knew how hard he went,
but when I was blasted out of my mind
and he was like,
where's that bottle?
Where's those joints?
And those like Jesus man.
Like I can't even.
I'm hanging onto the earth here.
Yeah.
It was a late night.
Yeah,
it was that one.
I mean,
listen,
they're like,
in all fairness,
not every night was quite like that,
you know?
We had a lot of fun that night for sure.
It was real fun and in a really
interesting,
thoughtful dialogue around the campfire
with super townie from backwoods country
hunters and anglers and all these other
guys that were with us or you know,
these guys who it was good to get a
different perspective on what going out
and getting your own wild food is like,
you know,
and then having him cook it there.
It was delicious.
Yeah.
It was awesome.
And,
but also being able to put those ideas
on like a major network and print.
Pretty rare.
Yeah.
Kudos to CNN for having the Kahunas to
put together that kind of a show and
have it on,
you know,
big time man.
What can I say?
This is the best creative partners you
could ask for in terms of that,
you know,
you really enjoyed that.
Yeah.
What's not?
That was the dream job.
You do what I do know you are interested
in making documentary television and you
know,
um,
that's it man.
That's the wind up.
Were there some other options?
Because I know he had a giant problem
with the travel channel because I know
he had told me that they,
they fucked him over and did some
Cadillac ad.
Yeah,
I know.
He was really pissed about the Cadillac
and.
Well,
what,
what was that about the I,
you know,
honestly,
I don't really know a lot of the details
of the whole story.
I don't know what other deals are on the
table besides Sienna,
but safe to say that the.
I think the relationship with travel
channel was toxic before that,
you know,
the travel channels,
religious own place at least was,
I don't know if still is,
I think the original people that owned
it because my friend Bert Kreischer has
a show over there.
I had a show over there,
a couple shows.
Birth to conquer.
And what was his other show?
Hurt Bert.
Yeah,
she's crazy asshole.
But uh,
you know,
Bert had issues with that too.
Like when he would be on the show,
if we'd all be hanging out together.
If you wanted to smoke pot,
he had to make sure that Jamie turn the
camera away from him.
Oh yeah,
because they couldn't see.
Oh No.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
You know,
but,
and listen,
I don't have any inside information,
so this is purely like my outside
perspective.
I don't do the deals and I don't deal in
that stuff and make the shows,
you know.
But uh,
you know,
I saw a network that was more interested
in making,
like,
you know,
the show's about sand castles,
you know?
Yeah.
The ghosts,
you know,
then they had a bunch of ghost shows,
shows her fucking popular.
Really popular man.
So stupid.
The dumbest fucking shows on television
and there's like 100 of them.
But the thing is if you're watching
everybody's scared of ghosts,
so if you're watching and it's like
people in there in the basement and they
have night vision on and they pretend
they see something like what are they
seeing as,
they're a fucking real ghosts,
cuts to commercial and then all of a
sudden you're hooked and you watch.
It's a hook after a hook.
After Hook.
Yeah.
It is the craziest,
weirdest thing.
It's one of the weirder things on
television.
Just got co showing the shoot.
Those shows,
can you imagine trying to make them
interesting like you were stumbling
around some fucking old house like with
night vision,
you know,
trying to.
Is that a fear now?
I mean,
look,
you're,
you went from mediator,
which is an amazing show and parts
unknown and no reservations and so
you've got these three amazing shows and
they put you on a go show.
No,
that's not a fear of mine.
That might be a nightmare.
That might be something I dream about.
Wake up sweating through my sheets,
you know?
No Man.
I'm,
I,
you know,
listen,
I still work for zero point zero,
you know.
Hi,
Morgan Morgan found it's Mike from
finding bigfoot.
Listen,
we're coming back for season 1000.
We're going to find them this year.
Please,
please come aboard.
We love what you did with Tony Bourdain
and we think you could do that with
Bobo.
You know,
but here's the thing,
they don't,
they don't want that.
They don't want,
they don't want cinematography and art,
you know,
they want.
Listen man,
they want some kid,
producer,
director slash cinematographer that they
can,
you know,
they don't want,
they don't want what we do.
Big Foot noises.
Oh yeah.
No.
And I'm still,
like I said,
I'm still with zero point zero.
Tony's longterm,
you know,
long time production company.
We do awesome work.
We got a ton of awesome stuff lined up.
You know,
we'll be okay ma'am.
But are you going to do more stuff with
Steve at mediator?
So I'll go out with steve anytime he
calls.
I just need a little more advanced
warning these days.
I think they called me last week to see
if I wanted to do an elk hunt.
Now if you do that,
would you try to get in shape first?
Like,
like heavy duty?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It was the last time I went out.
It was um,
I got my ass kicked.
It's fucking you kidding,
man.
Dude,
he's got,
I mean talk about a guy with like,
you know,
he has no empathy whatsoever for um,
for the people he's with.
Maybe can't keep up with no man.
When you're in the,
it's like if you can't make that hike,
you're just not making that hike,
you know,
and you know,
he weighs 110 pounds and he couldn't
walk for days.
Yeah.
And he's been doing this since he was a
baby.
Yeah,
exactly.
No,
man,
I went,
the last time I went out with him was
uh,
I guess two years ago I went up to
Alaska and did the blacktail hunt,
but we actually had nice weather,
which was kind of unbelievable because I
know you've been up there when it's
like,
you know,
10 days of rain coming sideways.
We had to leave early last time was
there because a storm was coming and we
had to make a decision that says I'm
coming every time we went up there,
but we weren't gonna be able to get out.
There was a possibility.
Exactly.
Part of me was like,
even though we're rain soaked,
I want to hunt the last six hours
because if I stay the last day,
never know that might be the,
that so many times that's when you hook
up with an animal.
Absolutely.
I mean,
in my experience up there with an
animal,
sounds like the wrong thing really,
really wrong because a couple of animals
and catch can.
No Man,
but you know,
like it was.
That's exactly the way it was.
You go up there and you'd be in six days
rain.
Then all of a sudden the fog a clear and
there's some,
you know,
black tail standing right there looking
at you.
You know that a lot of bear up there
too.
Yeah.
Tons of bear.
No,
but he,
you know,
I got my ass whipped last time.
I went up there first time I went up
there,
I was still in shape.
You know,
I was younger.
I did pretty well.
Well you were doing it all the time.
You have to do it all the time.
You have the hiking thing is something.
I mean you're,
you're basically building up this
difference in your legs that you only
get from hiking.
Absolutely.
Biking.
Endurance is no joke.
It seems like it's a joke because if you
hike for like five feet,
it seems like nothing.
You climbed a small hill.
Yeah.
I could do this all day.
You think you could do it all day?
You do that for 20 minutes.
You can start.
He even,
you'd be drenched in sweat.
He'd want to take your jacket off and
then you realize like,
oh my God,
I have to do this for eight more hours.
Eight more days.
Yeah.
And then the morning.
And then if your immune system,
is it all tax,
it's going to crash hard.
You might get sick.
Yeah,
man,
I know you,
like you said,
you can't train for it.
You can't train for that kind of back
country stuff.
You can go out and,
you know,
run up and down the stair master,
whatever,
but that doesn't really.
Doesn't train all those little muscles
that you use to constantly stabilize
yourself.
You know,
Senator Hassle,
help a little with stairmaster will help
a little but really helped the major
muscle groups.
Right.
Running hills,
uh,
helped me,
helped me a lot just because it's so
much harder than hiking.
He's run them.
You could do it easier.
It makes you hiking easier.
Lucky with weighted packs onto.
Do you ever do that?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that's what we did,
but not just for training.
For training.
Yeah,
I would.
I'm on the stairmaster actually.
I'm pretty sure I am.
I'm guessing the stairmaster with us.
Yeah,
no,
I'd put weights on my pack and go on the
stairmaster.
Yeah.
And boots,
you know,
boots on the stairmaster.
Did they let you do that at the gym
where they look at you weird or will
everyone looks at you weird?
Oh my God.
If you're,
if you even talk about hunting and Los
Angeles and looking at weird metro,
you know,
like
what's wrong with you?
It's the fuck that guy got Cammo on for
Jesus Christ.
Did you were camera with the gym?
I feel like I may have had some cammo
aspect of my pack of course,
but I'm bloodstains you know,
I,
you know,
it's interesting though because I think
back on those times and you know,
like while we're talking about like all
the shitty weather and all that stuff,
and then just think back to that.
The first time I went out with Steve,
him saying like,
Yeah Dude,
but you won't,
you know,
you never tell stories about the good
days,
you know,
and I got to say to his credit that's
been absolutely true is like those,
those shitty days,
freezing cold,
you know,
getting out of here,
getting out of your sleeping bag in the
morning and putting on wet clothes,
cold wet clothes to go to go out and
hunt all day.
You know,
I look back on that with like a great
degree of fondness and I also have to
say it made me a lot more of a person
than I was before,
you know,
toughens you up to it.
It,
it toughened me up to open me up to the
idea of it opened me up to accepting,
you know,
possibilities for myself that I had
never thought of before.
You know,
like your capabilities,
your capabilities,
you know,
that,
that we,
like,
we all have that somewhere back down in
the brainstem.
This idea,
this ability to just go out in the woods
and,
you know,
hunt something and eat it,
and up until that point I had never done
that.
I'd done some hiking and some camping.
It was always on trails and they're all
nicely marked and stuff like that.
The idea of stepping out of Steve's the
backdoor seeps cabin in just into the
woods at that time for me,
when I first did it,
that was completely new.
I was like,
well,
you can just walk into the woods,
where do we go and uh,
and then to do it and to have it be
successful and to bring that animal back
into sit around and eat it and all this
stuff.
That was a real huge Aha moment for me,
you know,
personally and professionally.
Like,
oh,
we can do shit that we used to do,
you know,
10,000 years ago.
It was big for me too.
I remember saying that on the show,
like when Steve was asking me and Brian
on the first hunt,
which just by sheer luck we were
successful on the,
on the first hunt.
Yeah.
And Steve was like,
a,
do you think you're going to do it
again?
I said,
fuck you.
I'm doing this forever.
Like,
I knew it.
He goes,
when did you know?
I said,
the moment that deer dropped.
Yeah.
The moment the deer dropped him,
like,
okay,
I'm doing this forever.
This is how I'm making,
getting my meat now I'm going to do
this.
Yeah,
man,
it's the,
it's shows.
I don't know.
There's so many.
Just like really glib interpretations of
like the motivation behind hunting,
you know,
I was say cruelty and blood lust and
it's like,
because in its worst cases that's,
that's true.
Yeah.
And because I,
I,
I do think that hunting shows for years,
that's a lot of what they put forward
was like kind of machismo and guys
shooting black bears over,
you know,
donut barrels,
um,
for all the wrong reasons,
you know,
the beliefs.
We think of that as something that
people,
or at least I do think of that as
something that people eat for food.
When you think about Cecil Cecil a
little while and that kind of shit
really sours people on the idea of
hunting because there's no justification
for the person for shooting
a lion.
I mean you have to,
you'd have to do decades of education
about conservation and the importance of
the money that goes for the hunt and
then they still don't get it because
they're like,
why would you want to shoot a line?
And that's the good question.
Good question.
Why would you want,
you know,
and I would say it's a good question for
me too.
I like,
I definitely have limits,
you know,
as much as I went around with Steve.
I have limits on what I would personally
choose to do and I got to say the Africa
stuff for me,
ma'am,
I just,
it's not interesting to me,
you know.
See that's interesting to me in Africa
would be to hunt something that I would
eat.
So they have antelope in Africa.
I would love to hunt and hunt and
antelope and cook it and eat it.
That to me,
makes sense.
There's no way I want to shoot a hippo
or anything else,
even if people do eat hippos and I
understand they do that.
Okay,
good luck.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't want to have nothing to do with
any of that,
but,
but game animals that have been,
that are delicious Neil Guy,
things like that,
that people have eaten forever and that
they hunt,
they hunt elk or deer here.
That to me makes sense.
It would be just an adventure to go to
Africa,
so fucking scary.
It's so sketchy.
I mean,
I love Africa and I became like,
I kinda took all the Africa shows I
could on parts unknown.
Really.
That's mostly wonderful place.
Well,
um,
first of all,
I think there's like a,
I think it's,
uh,
there's a lot of misperception when it
comes to.
I've never had a negative experience
there.
I've had maybe I had one experience.
It was kind of quasi threatening,
you know,
and we got to.
Yeah,
I mean,
you know,
we had a crowd kind of turn on us and
throw rocks at us was we were driving
away.
That's the one experience with like
hundreds experiences.
Well,
we're in a,
we're in Goma,
in the DRC,
you know,
and it's just a,
it's just a really,
really chaotic place.
A place has been run over by a civil
wars for decades.
People are in serious desperation,
but I think worse than any of that,
there's a huge culture of,
um,
of nonprofit organizations and stuff
there.
So I think they're used to kind of white
folks coming in with this very
patronizing kind of view.
Um,
and then we're down there with cameras
filming them and then all of a sudden
they realize that we're not paying
anyone for this,
you know,
and uh,
and I think,
you know,
there's a tendency for people to feel
like,
well,
you're here taking something from us,
you know,
you're clearly making more money than
any of us will ever be able to make.
And uh,
and what the fuck did we get for it?
You know,
and I can understand that point of view.
And how did it turn into them throwing
rocks at you guys?
You know,
again,
they realized we weren't going to be
paying for any of this.
You know,
our security team was like,
hey guys,
time to get in the car and as soon as
you get in the car and you're leaving,
it's like,
oh,
these fucking assholes,
man.
It just came down here,
got not older footage,
gonna pack up and go back to their nice
hotel,
you know?
Um,
but that's the one experience and little
like a lot of experiences there,
you know,
for the most part I found people that
are like incredibly gracious.
You know,
I've found it to be one of the most
hopeful places,
honestly.
Um,
my day to day experiences in Africa,
I saw people who were working their
asses off on a grassroots level.
The [inaudible] like some of the most,
um,
you know,
some of the most like dynamic grassroots
capitalism that I've ever seen and
people who will literally find any,
any way to scrape out an existence and a
living.
You know,
this is not like,
this is not a lazy culture.
This is a culture that will fight
through anything,
you know,
go to Lagos and legacy is one of the
most dynamic cities I've ever been in.
There's a constantly moving,
constantly people trying to make money,
constantly.
People trying to find a niche,
you know,
in a city of 20 million people,
so I find a lot of beauty and just like
raw human endeavor there.
And I think that,
you know,
if they can clear some of the,
like obvious stumbling blocks that they
have in terms of corruption,
in terms of,
you know,
foreign pressure,
um,
in terms of,
you know,
manipulation of markets.
Um,
there's,
there's tremendous promise there.
I mean like,
just,
just in terms of the,
just the Internet and technology sector
in Africa is absolutely booming.
You know,
you have kids that come in from the
villages on the streets of Lego's who
can take your computer apart and rebuild
it by hand,
you know,
self taught and all of that potential is
there to be tapped,
you know,
and,
and they're starting to,
you know.
So I guess I just find it a hopeful
place.
That's amazing that you only had one bad
experience,
only one,
only one.
But I can say that about traveling the
world kind of in general.
I mean we've been in a number of,
you know,
relatively hot zones.
I mean we never did active conflict
because we don't make that kind of show.
Um,
but you know,
being in places like Gaza or the DRC or
you know,
I can count on one hand in,
in many,
many years of doing this,
you know,
the number of times that I actually felt
threatened by someone.
You know,
I've found that the most likely
scenarios you're going to get accosted
by a sandwich,
you know,
or someone trying to,
introduce you to their kids,
you know,
or take a selfie with you.
And that's,
that's the world that I know.
I don't really understand the world that
we see on TV here,
man,
because that's not,
that's not my experience.
You know,
you know,
a lot of good people.
And again,
getting back to Tony,
I think that,
you know,
that's legacy,
right?
I think that he really showed people
that
that is a problem with our view of the
world is that if it doesn't look scary,
they're not gonna show it to,
you know,
just because if it's not dangerous,
I mean other than his show.
What else are you seeing on CNN where
they are in Africa where it's a good
thing.
What else are you seeing where people
are in Egypt where it's a good thing?
are interacting with people on the
street and there's not some sort of a
murder story or rape story or something
awful?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think you're starting,
you're starting to see it a little bit.
Um,
but mostly you're seeing it in like,
you know,
on like CNN,
Africa,
you know,
network or you know,
there you're starting to see them
covering stories about entrepreneurs,
right.
You know,
positive aspects,
you know,
building economies.
But it's a real problem in our view of
the world for people that don't travel
well.
Listen,
Africa just simply doesn't make news in
the United States.
I mean,
and yet it takes a genocide,
you know?
Well,
all I've been hearing about Africa
lately is what's going on with white
farmers in South Africa.
So yeah,
it's very scary stuff where people are
encouraging people to attack white
farmers,
you know,
and there's a whole lot of
sociopolitical economic shit that goes
on without that.
I'm not even going to pretend I
understand,
but uh,
that's what you hear about.
You don't hear about good things here
about how many farmers have been
murdered.
Yeah.
Homes.
Well that's a shame man,
because,
you know,
you go there and most of what I find
going on there as positive,
you know,
listen,
there's a lot of pain,
there's a lot of suffering,
there's a lot of bad shit that happens
there too.
Obviously.
I'm not gonna deny that,
you know,
but uh,
we don't hear the good stuff.
Did you have a good,
did you have like a place where you
enjoyed traveling to the most?
You know,
no,
I don't think really because uh,
I,
you know,
this,
to me,
this is another kind of like real lesson
of the show,
you know,
I think we got to a place where we were
finding something kind of everywhere,
you know,
there's some places that I didn't enjoy
as much,
you know,
but uh,
I think most places we found something
that was like,
oh,
this is,
this is awesome.
You know,
what was the one place where you like,
Eh,
I'm not going back here again.
I don't want to say,
okay.
The positive people keep it positive.
Let's just say it's a highly militarized
state.
Okay.
Now and deep divides and uh,
on both sides.
Yeah.
Okay.
And,
uh,
and a lot of beautiful people on both
sides,
but,
you know,
um,
but I think,
you know,
I mean this was something we like,
we encounter a lot as we kind of
progress in the show is this.
I,
you know,
I remember my dad would say it to me all
the time.
It's like,
well,
where,
where are you guys going to go now?
You know,
you've been everywhere.
It's just like,
yeah,
but I think we started to learn that you
could like really point the camera kind
of anywhere.
I think a big one for me was like doing
this West Virginia show last year,
which the place it always been like
really close to my heart.
Like I grew up there when I was a kid.
Um,
you know,
it's a place that has been,
I think like deeply misrepresented.
Again,
another place has been deeply
Ruttenberg,
misrepresented in the media,
you know,
um,
and uh,
but,
you know,
we got like I got into town on the scout
there and it's like there's no
restaurant,
you know,
it's not just that there's no restaurant
like in the town,
there's like two restaurants in the
county,
you know,
and I remember having this moment of
like,
can we do this,
this is work,
like will Tony Respond to this?
And we make a show here.
And within two days he was like,
this big,
you know,
very deeply heartfelt statements about
the place.
I really loved it,
you know,
and it was kind of another Aha moment
where you're like,
oh yeah,
of course.
Because there's something everywhere in
the human story is everywhere and dig
into it wherever you go,
the fundamentals of that don't change.
And I think that,
you know,
what he did was so cleanly and clearly
and so free of bullshit,
cut to the core of those very
fundamental kind of human stories,
you know.
And um,
anyways,
it worked well.
We won an emmy two nights ago for it.
So yeah,
posthumous Emmy's are always odd,
right?
Yeah.
That was a,
it was a rough night.
Um,
when he would get the rough cut,
would it be length of the actual show
and then he would add narration to it.
Did he have any say in the editing
process?
Huge.
I mean,
so I think that's something important
too about who he was,
you know,
um,
I mean like everyone calls him a chef.
He wasn't a chef,
like he was a producer,
he was a television producer,
you know,
um,
he,
he would pick the locations he had
picked a subject matter for the most
part.
You know,
there were a couple of lights.
How did you guys work it out?
Let's say if you were going to go to
Puerto Rico or something like that,
how would you make,
make the decisions,
how would you decide where to go and
why?
Okay,
well I'll take you through the whole
process.
So,
so tony would come up with a list of
places that he was interested in going
and maybe we would throw a couple in
light had mentioned the West Virginia
Show,
you know,
be like,
but this is my list,
right?
And um,
and then he'd write like a brief on each
one.
I'm interested in x,
you know,
like I'm interested in Singapore,
it's Disneyland with the death penalty.
Right.
And you're like,
okay.
So there's like,
there's kind of a basic operating
thesis,
right?
We can kind of like go in and look at
this place.
I'm from this perspective.
Um,
and so some of them,
some of them didn't add the Lego's
episode for example,
you just be like,
we,
we haven't been to Nigeria,
let's go to Nigeria,
you know,
and,
and so we would start doing research on
what that was just big kind of,
you know,
30,000 foot macro,
what is this environment like,
what are the interesting things,
what are the stories that have been told
about this place and how can we look at
it from a different angle.
So like the Nigeria one,
we kind of focused in on like I said,
you know,
grassroots capitalism dei,
why entrepreneurship,
you know,
street level,
the street level kind of dynamics of the
economy,
you know.
And that became like we could see ways
to kind of make a beautiful human story
out of those elements.
So I'd end up putting down to him
probably in like a two or three page
thing.
Like here are my ideas,
you know,
here's what I found based on what you
were interested in.
Here's some other things I've found,
this is the way we'd Kinda like to go
about it.
And he'd either be like,
yeah,
or no,
you know,
and from that point,
um,
we'd just get heavy into research,
write a treatment,
you know,
I'm in break that story into like six
acts,
right?
And then look for scenes to kind of fill
in,
articulate that story.
So it seems like,
you know,
I have this great economist,
I know we're going to need an economist
at some point,
but we got to put a,
economists are kind of boring by nature,
so we got to put him somewhere more
dynamic where there's this really
interesting computer market that has a
lot of energy.
So let's put the economists there.
They can walk around,
there's a great restaurant in the corner
there.
So like here's some elements we can put
together that's a scene in a act of the
show.
So you put all that stuff together and
treatment form,
send it to Tony,
usually minimal notes from him,
you know.
Um,
and then,
uh,
and then we'd go out and Scout,
shoot the show,
you know,
how weird is it shooting in a restaurant
with camera people standing over the
table?
I think we got,
I think we've got really good at not
taking over the environment,
you know,
so I don't,
I,
I don't know.
I don't know how to answer that because
you do it.
How do we save?
You and I are having a conversation at
dinner and we're being filmed right?
Is,
would they be as close as Jamie is?
Right there to cameras closer.
Not around.
On top of you.
Yeah.
It's pretty close.
But you know,
understanding.
Yeah.
But we wouldn't use like your,
there were rules to that,
right?
Because like we're a documentary show.
We can't just go in and just completely
take over some place or take over some
village or scare the shit out of local
people are,
you know what I mean?
Like we got to go in with some deafness,
you know,
so we would go in early and we would
light so that the character's Tony
aren't really seeing us screw around
with lighting,
stuff like that.
That's all kind of in place.
Um,
put the cameras in there.
No sound guy.
No big booms.
Sit the rest of the crew down.
Are they wearing wireless mics?
Yeah,
exactly.
And then,
and then,
uh,
and then fill in local people and the
rest of the restaurant and make sure
that there are people who actually go to
that restaurant in the restaurant,
make sure that fuels like alive,
not like full of extras,
like miming dialogue and
carrying large cameras.
Like how big are the cameras are
carrying their big cameras,
like regular big ole production cameras,
heavy on the shoulders.
Like you guys would use a mediator.
Yeah.
Again,
you know,
but again,
it's two guys standing there with
cameras that have been traveling,
at least from Tony's perspective and
traveling with Tony for a long time.
You know,
it was just like having two more friends
at the meal in terms of what the
sidekicks,
you know,
I think we learned early on that like
you gotta like you gotta go up,
you've got to introduce yourself,
you've got to smile,
you gotta laugh,
you gotta be able to be self deprecating
and make them feel comfortable.
Like you're there to ask them questions,
not to tell them who they are,
you know.
And um,
I don't know,
man,
it,
I,
I just say we,
we traveled all over the place.
A lot of people who've never been on
camera for that largely worked,
you know,
so it must've been doing something
right.
Was there ever a time you in a
restaurant in.
We're pissed off that there was people
standing there with cameras filming a
table.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But you know,
that's pretty easy.
You know,
someone gets pissed off and they wave
you off.
Okay,
cool.
Sorry.
No,
no worries.
You know,
I,
it never really escalated,
you know,
listen,
may never escalated.
You had a view of the world by doing
that show and traveling the way he did
that it's less than one percent of the
population is ever gonna experience.
Probably less than one percent of one
percent.
Yeah,
I would say for sure.
Yeah.
I mean it's got to be an incredibly
enriching journey for you.
Yeah,
hugely.
I mean,
here's Lee.
There's,
I mean it's,
I don't know,
it's very simple.
There's before and there's after and
it's two different people really,
because just all the data you had to
take in the view of the world changes,
it gets bigger.
It becomes a much bigger place.
It does.
That's was,
you know.
That's exactly right and not what's
really interesting.
I tell people this too,
they'd be like,
oh well,
you know,
you've been all these places.
It's get out of the gap,
but the world doesn't work like that.
It doesn't sound like the more places
you go,
the smaller the world feels more places
you go.
The bigger the world feels.
It just feels bigger and bigger and
bigger because he realized like there's,
you know,
people,
every country,
there's this county in this country,
in this town,
in this county,
there's this street,
there's all these other streets,
there's all these other people.
You know,
our shows were just a sliver of a place,
a tiny little sliver,
you know,
you can go into Lego's.
We'd go back to Lego and make 10 more
shows.
Each one of them completely unique and
individual.
You know,
the world's a big place.
A lot of shit
going on.
Know,
yeah,
now
they're going to keep hearing shows,
right?
I mean,
how long are they going to,
how long are they going to do this for?
They have.
How many did they have all told?
How many they did?
Five seasons.
Actually it's an 18.
I guess we're getting near 100 shows,
you know,
I've never counted.
I don't really know a lot of shows.
Uh,
yeah,
they'll keep her.
I have it on my dvr so they'll
occasionally run these marathons and
then I'll go to my dvr and there's like
20 new shows,
you know,
and I've watched a few of them the other
night for the first time I watched it in
awhile.
I posted a thing on instagram too about
it because I,
I was real reluctant to watch it after
he died.
But then I went on a bender wash,
like binged watched like three of them
in the night.
I was like,
God damn on a good show.
It was.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was good man.
You guys nailed it and you really,
you should be really proud.
Thanks man.
Yeah,
and you know,
I'm actually still working on one right
now,
which is maybe the weirdest experience.
You know,
you're asking about process before,
you know,
after we chewed it,
that's when Tony really came in.
What do you do if he's not there for
narration?
Well,
that's the,
that's the thing.
Who narrates it,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not going to replace Tony,
so no narration now.
Yeah.
I mean we have our sidekicks,
uh,
talking to him.
We have his dialogue in the field,
you know,
but who's going to step in and do that
voice and how offensive would it be if
we did that?
It would happen
to be someone who is so close to him
that it didn't,
it didn't freak everybody out and have
to be someone who was on the show a
thousand times.
It was just there with them always.
Yeah.
That person doesn't really exist.
Doesn't?
Yeah,
there's no,
there's no voice there.
When you would give him a rough cut,
I'm safe.
Like I said,
a show on Puerto Rico,
what have you.
So he would take that,
he would watch it and then he would
start writing.
Exactly.
So yeah,
getting back to process,
you'd like,
I'd send him an act right once it was in
rough cut form and then you get his
notes back because that was always kind
of a terrifying moment too because
you're like,
dude,
you worked on the thing a lot and you
send it off to him.
He can go one way or another.
Man,
I got you.
I got gutted a few times but I got a
couple that were like out fucking
standing,
you know,
and that's all the notes he had.
But you would,
you'd send them basically scratch
writing.
So you'd say like here's what we're
thinking,
you know,
is this kind of idea,
goes here,
this kind of idea goes here.
And then he would actually write it,
you know,
and you get that writing back.
How long will it take for him to do
something like that?
Oh he ripped that shit out,
man.
Yeah,
he fast.
And that's the thing too.
I never,
you know,
there was never an email or a text that
he didn't get back to you because he was
no slouch man.
He liked,
he was sharp,
he was on it.
He'd get back to you,
he'd do the work,
you know,
it.
Um,
when he took pride in that,
we would talk about doing the work.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And he did.
I mean,
there's another,
that's another,
another thing that was so delightful
about it,
you know,
suddenly you're having to drag some,
carcass along and,
you know,
prop them up in front of the camera and,
he was into it man.
And like he had total ownership,
total control,
awesome.
Incredible creative ideas,
incredible creative power.
Like he was in,
you know,
and no show was like,
yeah,
fuck it,
you know,
we can just kind of slipped by on this
one.
You know,
every show is important and when they,
you know,
when they weren't working,
he was pissed,
you know,
and great.
You know,
I think the biggest thing that I miss in
this process of cutting this Texas show
that I'm doing now is not having the
pressure of him looking at it and being
like,
dude,
you know,
no man,
this ain't working.
You know,
that was a real benefit to us.
Huh?
When did he start smoking again?
You know,
so weirdest thing,
man,
I,
I didn't know.
I didn't really know his smoking again.
And then the police show came out and I
just saw him light up on camera,
you know,
I was like,
Oh shit,
I guess we're doing this again.
And then a couple of my,
like a couple of my shows at the end,
he'd start just lighting up on Cameron.
That was always like,
that was always no go territory.
Like in the past when he was smoking,
we would like stop shooting,
you know?
Um,
all of a sudden he was just lighting up
right on camera and
I don't know,
shocked the shit out of me,
you know,
I kind of looked around,
the crew liked w,
what do we do?
Like
I was shocked because he said that when
his daughter was born is when he decided
to stop smoking because he realized
that,
you know,
he had something else to live for that
he,
you know,
he didn't want to be on some cancer bed.
Fuck Iron Long.
Having his daughter visit him.
Yeah.
So he quit.
Yeah,
it was a bummer when you started again.
That's,
you know,
did he stop going to Jujitsu?
I don't know.
I,
it
here's,
it wasn't as frequent during the end,
you know,
uh,
during the last few episodes,
I know we stopped kind of having to find
gyms.
Um,
and we'd offer,
you know,
and be like,
Nah,
I'm cool.
So I think the last couple of shows
would probably like that for me.
I was like,
you want to find local gym?
It'd be like,
Nah,
you know,
I'm good man.
So was it within the last year or so,
or less.
Less than a year.
So he's the last year or so.
Yeah.
So that's when the smoking started.
I guess maybe a little earlier in that.
Yeah,
that's a bummer.
When you see someone quit and then go
back on,
that is one of the weirder it is of our
culture.
Does he got through.
I mean,
he got through the really hard part,
you know,
couple of years under his belt and you
look great man.
He was,
you know,
really,
uh,
he was doing really well.
Now
where do you go from here?
Where do I go from?
Oh Shit,
I didn't,
you know,
um,
I,
you know,
Tony Gay I think gave us tremendous
tools to,
you know,
for how we look at the world and like
how we will continue to go on looking at
the world and um,
I don't know exactly what show I'll do,
but I know it will continue that kind of
ethos,
you know,
and I'm like,
I feel like I have this very powerful
kind of,
um,
no,
like I said,
set of tools now that,
that he kind of handed us and you know,
that,
uh,
to go on and keep doing this work,
you know,
isn't the problem with this work that
you need someone like him?
He kind of need like either a Rinella
who's a very unique person and in many
ways similar,
not self-destructive at all,
but really meticulous about his work and
a very good writer as well and his
narration,
like one of the things that separates
mediator from any other show is that
Steve has this eloquent narration
exactly that goes to it and it makes you
realize like our perception of what it
means to be a hunter is based on
stereotypes,
negative stereotypes that this is the
best example.
This is a really well read,
brilliant man who has a great passion
for the outdoors and for public lands
and for wildlife and for consuming
wildlife in this,
this,
this adventure of pursuing it and eating
it and cooking it and showing you the
art of cooking.
You know,
the that you,
you wouldn't be able to make meat eater
with pig.
Man.
I can't even talk about
the apocalypse.
Yeah,
I mean,
come on.
Well,
unfortunately I enjoyed that
with,
for all the wrong reasons.
There's justification to joining a pork
lips,
first of all,
because you got Ted nugent with a
machine gun in the helicopter.
Okay,
and then two,
you have this real wild pig epidemic.
It's a legitimate epidemic in Texas and
they don't know how to eradicate them.
I guess
all that,
and I've been putting it on television
on a hunting show.
It's not really hunting,
it's assassinating out of a helicopter
and they're laughing and that it's that
part.
It's the mentality behind it.
The,
you know,
I'm like,
listen,
I'm not saying don't have fun on a hunt.
I've bet a lot of fun on hunts,
you know,
and a great time on a hunt.
I don't know.
There's something about,
you know,
just,
you know what you're saying.
I know.
Exactly.
Firing off a thousand rounds,
cackling inside of a helicopter.
Yeah.
Laughing when you see pigs do
somersaults because you had shot at him.
A helicopter,
you know,
I
think I think is one of the things I
really loved about Steve,
you know,
like,
or love still that I still love about
Steve.
Um,
you know,
a really poignant episode on that show
for me.
It was when we went up to Alaska and
we're hunting black bear and uh,
and he decided not to take a shot,
you know,
I mean,
here's a guy that loves animals as much
as he loves hunting animals as much as
he loves conservation of animals as much
as he loves the knowledge and the
science behind animals and the natural
world,
you know.
Um,
that to me was appealing.
Like that's something I can sink my
teeth into,
dedicate my efforts towards,
you know,
from working on.
Yeah,
it was a crazy show,
man.
I mean,
I talked to him about it and his sort of
idea of why he didn't do it was so
interesting.
He just kind of went with his feelings.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
To have a hunting show where you have a
bear,
which is what you're looking for,
lined up in your scope and go,
I don't want to do it.
I'm not feeling it in a,
in.
I loved what he said to at the time.
So he was like,
I'm not saying I'm never going to shoot
a bear again.
I just don't want to shoot a bear today.
And I'm not gonna and that I,
that was a big moment,
man.
That's.
Well,
that's the words coming out of his
mouth.
How conflicted must his perception be to
realize that?
Okay,
I'm filming a show where I'm actively
hunting bears his camera people.
There's a budget behind it.
Now I have to make a show about my
decision to not have to bear and then
next week I'm going to go hunt something
else and then the next week I'm going to
go hudson something else.
Yeah.
But I mean that like his ability to,
to like admit and kind of understand
that the human being is a complex animal
with complex emotions and that,
you know,
this idea of just kind of uniform
direction of the human mind is like a
total fallacy.
Man.
We're all over the fucking place,
you know?
And like,
I dunno,
I really bought in at that moment if I
hadn't before,
which I completely kind of had,
but I really bought in at that moment.
I was like,
whew,
this is,
this is a guy I can always stand behind.
You know,
one of my favorite episodes.
Brave.
It was brave because you realized this
is on the sportsman's network.
Yeah,
so the sportsmans channel and they have
only hunting shows.
Oh Man.
And then he's on a hunting show with you
got all these people that are watching
that would kill to be on a hunt like
that and to have a big old bear in their
sites what they want and they're
thinking,
we're going to see Steve shoot this.
Then we're going to see them cook up a
bear rose and he's getting a c stewed
carrots and onions and potatoes and
there's going to be amazing and he's
got,
I don't want to do it.
And everybody's like,
why?
Yeah.
And we were like,
we're
really nervous.
I remember when the episode came out was
this and when we had done a few things
before,
like we had failed at a hunt.
Like,
you know,
we had taken shots that missed in the
hunt failed.
We had gone on a mountain lion hunt
where we never even thought mountain
land.
Those were all kind of moments where
like,
will this work?
Can we put this out in the hunting
community?
Will they respond to it in every one of
those had kind of like hit or worked and
I think people actually appreciate it
because of the realism of it,
you know,
that one was like,
can you,
can you put out a show where there's a
perfectly legitimate shot at a very high
percentage shot at,
uh,
at exactly the animal we're going after
and the choice to not take the shot,
you know,
how are People gonna Respond?
Overwhelmingly,
people were like,
hey man,
I know exactly how you feel.
You know,
it was incredible,
you know,
it was like,
it was like this moment and I don't mean
to bag on anyone else,
man.
And I don't know that much about hunting
shows before,
you know,
I know that a lot of what I saw I found
to be really,
really either uninteresting or just
fucking stupid,
you know.
But,
um,
you know,
I think that it was like this moment
where like,
oh my God,
like,
all these,
you know,
this,
this industry is like,
missed a big,
big part of who the people you know,
that are paying attention here are,
you know,
um,
you don't have to just go like sell
arrowheads,
you know,
and uh,
and cackle hanging out of a helicopter.
Yeah,
well that's worst case example,
but for some hunting people that are
like sort of a deeply indoctrinated into
the world of hunting,
they don't mind that show.
None of mine.
And he listened and no power,
more power to them.
I,
I'm not,
I'm not trying to tell anyone how to be
or what to like or was
a lot of guys like Steve.
I mean,
do you know Donny Vincent?
No.
Similar guy.
Yeah.
Really,
really smart guy.
And a just great reverence for the
outdoors and for wildlife.
And you know,
he does everything self filmed and sells
the asco films.
He's smart,
you know,
he knows,
he knows what he's doing.
Cool man.
But he,
um,
you know,
Steve,
he sort of changed the perception of
hunting for a lot of people that have
become fans of his show the same way
that Tony sort of changed the
perceptions.
Absolutely.
End of cooking.
Yeah.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I mean I'm not like terrence malick or
something,
but like I got a lot to offer and I got
to,
I got a career.
I'm not gonna I'm not going to dedicate
my career to these people unless I
really,
really believe in what they're doing.
And like that's,
those are two cases of people really
believe in man because they were willing
to look at an industry or look at
something that they loved and say like,
well,
I have a completely different take on
it,
you know,
and I'm willing to put that out there.
Whatever cost.
And in both cases at work,
because they're both super smart,
you know,
I'm really capable people,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't think I've ever met really
anyone more capable than steve and a lot
of ways guy is a,
he's,
he's kind of a force of nature.
You know,
he's a very unique person and um,
and uh,
the,
the amount of stuff that he's able to
get done as well,
you know,
written a bunch of bugs and constantly
doing these shows and just the
enthusiasm to mean he's not just going
to these places and staying in hotels.
He's sleeping on the ground outside in
these,
you know,
really fucked up places and you know,
about a fog back.
What happened with the bear attack?
I do.
Yeah.
Which is just,
if anybody doesn't know,
there's a two part series on the
mediator podcast about a fog,
NAC,
which is an island in Alaska where they
have enormous brown bears and they got
charged and attacked by a fucking 11
foot bear,
which is just so crazy to think of.
And the description of it.
And then they made this podcast right
after the fact.
So it's fresh in everyone's mind.
It is amazing.
It's amazing.
So amazing story.
It's also amazing of center.
First time he has been charged and uh,
you know,
by a number of different animals,
it was run over by a moose.
Yeah.
You know.
But I will say that,
I mean,
you get,
Steve also is like physically one of the
toughest people I've ever met.
I mean,
I watched him set a beaver traps one
time in,
I mean,
breaking ice with his bare fist to set
beaver traps for hours,
you know,
put your hand in that water for put your
hand in that water for two minutes,
you know,
just bad.
Someone who does not have trouble,
you know,
enduring during a lot of physical
discomfort.
And uh,
and that was what was kind of exciting
about the show too,
is he was really like willing to
integrate that stuff into the
experience.
You know,
it wasn't like,
it wasn't like we need to go out,
we need the perfect kill shot,
we need to set this up.
When you said that,
it was Kinda like,
well,
we're just going to go out and we're
going to see what happens.
We're going to kind of grit our teeth
and bear it no matter what,
you know,
the,
where the journey takes us and we're
just going to document that.
Um,
that was super exciting television to
make at that time too,
is that,
you know,
I've done five episodes of his show and
we struck out on two of them,
[inaudible],
you know,
that's a,
it used to be.
They will never air shows like that.
No,
I don't know that they aired.
I mean,
I'll probably,
I'm sure a lot of people will be like,
yeah,
dude,
you don't know what you're talking
about,
but I'm not sure that they aired a lot
of failed hunts before we started doing
it.
I don't think they did.
I don't think it was a popular thing and
it might've been done before,
but not to the extent the way Steve did
one of my favorite episodes.
He never,
never shot a deer.
It was talking about his dad.
He was brilliant and I think that was
Alaska as well,
wasn't it?
I don't think it was,
it was.
It wasn't a blacktail hunt,
maybe it wasn't Alaska.
No,
I feel like it was a cruise deer hunt,
I think.
And Arizona.
And um,
most of the show was him using a
spotting scope and binoculars,
looking for deer and talking about his
relationship with his father and there
was no music.
Whoever edited it and put it together,
it was brilliant.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Because it was,
you know,
some heavy,
heavy duty shit and it sort of makes you
realize like,
oh,
this is where you came from.
You came from a hard man.
Yeah.
Taskmaster.
You know,
um,
that was a brilliant episode is also
like,
I think,
you know,
one of the things I liked so much about
that episode too is it feels so much
like the process of hunting,
you know,
it's um,
long hours with people really kinda
getting deep into stuff.
And I,
you know,
I did an episode with him too.
I,
it hasn't aired yet.
Um,
but it was a lot of that I lead it like
just talking about life,
you know.
Yeah.
I really enjoyed that part of Vietnam
with him until a written spending those
long hours just sitting glassing hills,
like talking about our families and you
know,
plans for the future.
And,
uh,
it was nice,
man.
I listened.
I feel,
I can't tell you how lucky I feel in my
career to like landed with these folks,
you know?
Yeah.
That's a great one too,
right there,
those two,
those two guys.
Yeah.
But like we were saying,
it's real hard to find those kind of
guys.
There's not a lot of those kinds of guys
out there.
There's not a,
you know,
um,
I think,
you know,
it feels like there's more of what they
call premium content now,
you know,
on tv there's more people looking for
things that have more substance to it.
But that is.
What do you think has happened?
What's the shift?
I,
you know,
I got,
I guess I don't really know.
I think I'm,
I'm not in development so I'm not really
in a,
you know,
a place to say.
But um,
I get the feeling that outlets like
Netflix have really shaken up the,
uh,
the paradigm,
you know,
I think the Internet in general has
changed people's expectations and,
and uncensored content is so prevalent
and so much more attractive.
And yes,
it's,
it's just changed,
changed the way people absorb things.
Yeah,
I think that,
you know,
I think I,
I think,
you know,
listen,
Netflix is there,
spent a lot of money.
They've taken a lot of swings,
not all of those swings of Hit,
but they've been pretty brave in terms
of like how much and how would a wide
range of content they've been willing to
take on.
And uh,
and so,
uh,
you know,
again,
I,
maybe that's part of what's driving it.
Um,
I know,
um,
I've been lucky enough to land at,
like I said before,
like zero point zero with Chris and
Lydia there and their ethos of,
you know,
making content that like has a purpose,
that that works towards bettering,
you know,
the world or showing people something
about the world or you know,
connecting people.
And uh,
and that's probably been the greatest
gift.
That's what brought me in a Tony.
That's what brought me to Steve.
You know,
there's a connection with them.
So there are people out there that want
to use the medium to.
Yeah,
they're,
they're idealistic suckers.
Well,
one of them,
that's what creates that satisfying art.
I mean,
the stuff that we're talking about you,
you're not going to get that any other
way.
You have to have those people with that
deep reverence for the subject that
they're discussing,
the subject that's being portrayed.
Yeah.
And in now again,
more and more we have the outlets to put
that on the air.
Hey,
think back to the days when it was three
networks,
you know,
Tony's never again
on the air.
Now we'll never going to find out about
him.
I mean,
he'll have to stick with being an
author.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Um,
it's,
it's a lot of ways.
It's the wild west now,
but in a lot of ways that's
a good thing.
Oh,
it's a good thing.
I mean,
it's great thing for me.
Nobody would ever giving me a fucking
show.
It wouldn't have been that crazy.
This kind of show where it go.
So what do you want to do?
I just want to talk to you was going to
schedule it me,
what are you going to do on the show?
Whatever format of discussion.
Dope.
But it a lot of ways.
That's what Kinda,
that's what mediator was in the hunting
version,
you know,
it was like,
what's the concept of the show?
Well,
I'm going to hit the shit that I want to
hunt when you go to places I want to go
and hang out with the people I want to
hang out with.
Well,
you know,
are you going to shoot animals?
I don't know.
Maybe,
maybe not.
It's something I can't tell you we're
going to try.
And uh,
I was,
man again,
it was great to be able to do that and
have that freedom.
And I think CNN,
a lot of ways,
like,
you know,
when Tony,
that,
you know,
to have the freedom to be like,
well,
here's a,
you know,
60 year old,
ex heroin addict.
Um,
we're gonna do whatever he wants to do.
We're going to go wherever in the world
he wants to go and we're just going to
kind of let him talk right now.
Um,
well the,
the Seattle one,
they let them get blasted.
I mean,
he was,
he was smoking weed on camera,
smoking weed through the show,
going and visiting growers and then
going to restaurants high as fuck,
like you could tell he was high and he
was talking about I been smoking all
day,
talking about being baked with two
people who are growers,
the brother and sister with her of Larry
[inaudible].
There were a whole.
I know they were laughing with them and
it's like the whole family's involved is
really.
That was a great episode band and it
also,
fuck God damn.
That episode got me hungry because you
like,
you see all the seafood in Seattle and
all the delicious food.
I haven't been up there.
No,
that was a good episode.
Um,
in those,
those folks were awesome.
I went out to that place and I filmed
that and it's like they were like,
it was like dream scenario.
I mean that kid.
Like he,
he put together the names.
I'm trying to remember it.
It'll look just to give them a shout out
Seattle episode.
I'm growers.
It'll come up African American family.
But um,
they were awesome.
They were awesome.
And like,
you know,
that was all that kid he had put
together a pdf,
showed his family and they were like,
cool,
let's sync everything into it.
And they did and I went out to their
place and they were just sitting back
laughing,
you know,
like counting stacks,
some money,
you know,
and all smoking joints,
grandma's there smoking a huge doobie.
She was like quality control testing
these kids working for them and stuff
like,
you know,
rolling joints and they can oil and,
and it was just like,
it was like good for you guys,
you know,
like,
like way to go.
Isn't that the way of like kind of
American entrepreneurship is supposed to
work well,
it's just rare that something comes
along.
This is controversial,
but yet also lucrative has marijuana
sales and then all of a sudden it's
legal in the state.
Totally.
And you're like,
oh,
okay,
well we could just do this.
Yeah.
I'll tell you what's funny.
The controversial part of that episode
was not Tony Smoking because that's
legal.
It's perfectly fine for him to smoke.
It was when he handed the joint to me
over the camera.
That one was a little.
I think that was a little tough for some
folks to swallow as well because.
Because I'm working,
you know,
but he's working too.
Yeah.
Well,
Geez,
you know,
I never thought of it that way.
I guess he was working.
Yeah,
he's worked
with,
I guess is the idea that you're holding
machinery the Hollingsworth.
That's right.
Shout out to the Hollingsworth's
Hollingsworth farm.
Hollingsworth far.
Yeah,
they are.
Yeah.
Why was it,
I guess because maybe they're thinking
you're holding a machine that's real
expensive gas man or the.
I think they,
you know,
they didn't want the perception that we
were just partying and out of control in
the field and we,
and we weren't man,
you know,
we're like,
we're professionals.
So did CNN have a problem with it?
I think maybe there were elements at
CNN.
Someone might've had,
someone must have chimed in,
but in the end,
again,
to their credit,
in the end I left,
you know,
they left us alone.
Like,
you know,
that's the only way would make a good
show.
Yeah.
As soon as I was fucking cook,
start coming into the kitchen and still
and wanting to add ingredients.
Yeah,
but that's the whole industry.
I know.
That's the process on believable.
Again.
That's why this was so refreshing.
You know,
how rare is it not to get,
not to have people just breathing down
your neck.
All the ton of.
Same thing with mediator because Steven
Rinella came from the wild within,
which was a show that that's where I met
him.
I met him from that show and I had him
on my podcast,
but that show was a fucking goat rope.
He was telling me that they were trying
to let animals loose out of cages and
then he would shoot them.
Those were the early days when they're
like.
Then when they were like,
there were line items in for like animal
wrangler and like,
but you know,
to everyone's credit and like very
quickly at zero point zero.
I'm very quickly with Steve,
there were like,
dude,
we don't do that.
Like we're not doing that.
But it's hilarious at a producer
actually came up with that idea like,
oh,
I know how to do this.
Producer didn't know it sounded like a
producer came up with that idea.
That was just a playbook on how you make
tv just pulling from the playbook for
sure.
You know,
I mean air quotes,
TV.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
bad show.
I mean,
listen,
there's,
there's a lot of huge mistakes in that
show and a lot of bullshit.
Um,
though it was,
I thought it was a pretty revolutionary
in a pretty interesting show in a lot of
ways.
Um,
there's a lot of truth in there too,
you know,
we did end up going out and just like
going on hunts,
you know,
this is a very high pressure situation,
but also like this is very typical of
kind of like the,
I think the way that television works,
there's like still as we're out in the
field,
there's still at the network a lot of
kind of infighting and jostling about
what the show actually was.
Is this a,
is this history,
is this,
you know,
reality?
Is this subsistence?
Yeah.
You know,
I remember at one point someone saying
something like,
well,
it's not a hunting show,
you know,
and we're like,
I'm like in the field covered in fucking
moose blood,
you know,
and I'm like,
well,
it looks like a hunting show from where
I'm standing,
you know,
like,
I don't know what to say.
What does that mean?
You're saying it's not a hunting show?
Yeah,
I think that there's,
you know,
I don't remember who that was,
but I think that they were very leery of
this idea of like a hunting show.
What was the subsistence shows that they
have?
They're all hunting and gathering.
I mean that is like one of the more
popular shows on all of these cable
channels where these,
these people that live in Alaska and
they're trapping now.
It is,
shoot.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It wasn't then.
I know it's crazy.
I mean not John,
we're really exploded after that.
Yeah.
And I think there's something very
different,
you know,
when you take like a,
when you take like,
I don't know,
for some reason when you take Steve,
the New York City intellectual and you
put them in that environment,
I think there was a different reaction
then like,
oh,
these people live
in Alaska.
It's like watching pygmies hunt,
you know,
there are these certain days,
this is the natural environment of,
you know,
and that's what they do.
And so hunting is acceptable under those
conditions.
You know,
it's like,
why isn't it acceptable for someone who
like lives it as like a base philosophy
in their life.
Give them a chance to explain why,
you know.
But he lives in Brooklyn.
Why would you ever hunt,
you know,
you live in Brooklyn,
just go to the shopping center.
Well,
yeah.
Well you must be,
there must be something wrong with you
if you enjoy it.
Right,
exactly.
And I think that's,
I think that's part of the mentality.
Well,
Tony Address
on the show too,
you know,
I remember one of the first times tony
shot a deer on the show and then they
cooked it at that same guys restaurant.
Yep,
exactly what?
Marco Pierre White at his restaurant and
they shot a deer and Marco put the blood
on Tony's head.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's supposed to do and you get your
first kill.
And then um,
they went and cooked it and it was a,
there was a lot of that,
there was,
there was one time where he shot a pig
at point blank range with a pistol and I
was like,
wow,
they put that on TV.
It was a big.
That was a big moment for him.
He tell you talked about that a lot.
Yeah.
So,
well,
I mean,
uh,
he um,
that was Cajun country,
right?
Yeah.
And um,
I think that,
I think he,
I think the story goes that he liked,
he goes,
they asked him to kill the pig and he
goes up and like just very,
very coldly double taps the pig in the
head.
And I think that he says there's just
this moment of silence amongst the
crowd,
like,
oh Geez man,
was that,
that was cold dude.
What do they expect?
I don't know.
But he was like,
he,
he would talk about it as if like a gasp
came up from the crowd was like,
Geez,
wow.
You know,
the Donald,
you know,
like was like a mob hit or something.
Yeah.
I think one is enough for a pig blank
range.
I've seen animals shot in the head
though.
That could have used another one.
Really?
Yeah.
That's why I think especially with Jesus
I've seen,
I've seen a couple of pigs go real ugly.
So double tap is totally acceptable to
me because when a pig goes bad,
it's really not pleasant for anyone,
man.
Yeah.
Well it's also,
you don't want an animal ever to suffer
if you.
Exactly see it's still alive,
but another one in it.
That's always.
Yeah.
Bow Hunting,
rifle hunting.
If it's still standing,
put another one in it.
Yeah.
Or suffering in any way.
I mean,
I think that's,
you know,
um,
that's like kind of a responsibility you
take on yourself when you decide to
hunt.
For me,
um,
when I made that decision and I've been
on two hunts now with Steve,
I've shot two deer.
That was like a very clear kind of
aspect of it,
you know,
it was like,
well,
I'm taking responsibility now,
not only like this animal's life,
but for this animal's pain and suffering
and the consequences of my actions,
you know,
so I'm not going to be lobbing off any
750 yard,
you know,
rifle shots because I'm not qualified to
do that.
And it's irresponsible to the animal and
the potential suffering that you can
cause,
you know,
um,
or losing the animal or you know,
so,
um,
you know,
and I don't know,
I guess that all comes from Steve
Really,
you know,
at least he's got such strong ethics.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I mean it became really clear,
uh,
with me just knowing him that this guy
is a,
he's got a,
like a very,
very powerful moral compass.
Yeah.
Core set of beliefs that are just non
negotiable.
Again,
both of them.
Tony and Steve,
I mean Tony,
his moral compass is rock solid as well,
you know,
um,
any mistakes that he may have made in
his life,
I can honestly say he made them with his
heart.
He made him with his moral compass in
mind and making his best attempt to,
to follow that,
you know,
um,
and again,
that,
you know,
that was something that was,
it was really nice to be around a
refreshing of urine,
you know,
Brian especially in this world of people
with gimmicks trying to become more
popular and more well known.
And he had put zero effort into that.
Yeah,
I mean,
just the basic philosophy of the show.
We're not going to fake anything.
We're not going to do second takes.
We're not gonna know what the one where
they were thrown frozen octopus.
So this is like a really famous story,
right?
The Sicily episode.
Yeah.
And he describes that is like the,
maybe the darkest existential moment of
his life,
you know,
it was like,
who is throwing the fake octa?
The frozen side kicks,
so they set up these sidekicks who were
like the guy who was running the fishing
operation will,
I guess they were the psychics and the
scene that we're gonna work with Tony.
Right.
So the way you'd set a scene up normally
like that is you'd have like a psychic,
someone who's going to talk to Tony and
be like,
Hey,
what are we going to do?
Oh,
we're going to go out.
And the sidekick would be a local,
like a local or
an expert in something or you know,
a fisherman.
Probably in this case,
I wasn't on that trust.
I don't know exactly.
But um,
you know,
and you'd be like,
oh,
we're going to go walk to us.
Do you know someone who fishes octopus?
Oh yeah,
I know so and so,
and we'll go out with them.
Right.
So,
but it turned out that they went to like
this very crowded beach,
you know,
and I think even in the scene,
can we really catch activists?
They're just like people swimming or a
kids with like a snorkel masks,
you know,
and like,
yeah,
yeah.
Everything's gonna be fine.
He got in the water and he starts
hearing these plops.
It looks above him.
And is these dead octopus,
like floating,
drifting down to the bottom of the
ocean.
They're lobbing them in off the boat and
then picking them up as of late.
I got an octopus,
a got one,
you know,
but I,
I think again,
like most TV shows that do exactly that,
you know like where's the octopus
wrangler and for Tony,
like that was always completely
unacceptable way to make tv.
So he had no idea it was going to happen
before it started happening.
No,
no.
I started happening.
What did he say?
He,
he left and went to the beach in order
to like get like seven Negroni's in a
row.
He was really bummed out about it.
I saw him two weeks later in Tokyo and
he was still talking about it because
like I just,
I just had the worst experience of my
life.
Worst thing that ever happened to me,
the darkest moment of my life,
the darkest moment of throwing frozen
octopuses to the water,
completely went against the whole ethos
of the show,
but he made fun of it on the shelf.
Listen,
honestly,
it's a great scene.
It's a great.
It's a great scene.
It largely because Sally Freeman,
the producer of that is like absolutely
brilliant and one of the best directors
has ever come through that show.
So yeah,
it was funny to take on realizing that
they were throwing frozen octopus into
the water.
Exactly.
Like how mortified he was bi at all.
Yeah,
totally.
But I mean I bet that again,
like that's,
that's the way it was,
you know,
like we didn't go in and like be like,
okay,
action and now cut.
Okay,
now we're going to move the cameras and
say that again.
You know,
there's none of that man.
You.
I mean,
part of the hustle of the show was like
being there with the camera.
Yeah.
You set up the scene and then you press
play and you let it go.
And what happens happens.
And I'm sorry if you don't get exactly
what you hoped out of it,
you know,
but we're not going to interrupt the
world.
We're not going to manipulate and
control things.
That is the difference between really
good reality TV in the word reality TV
is so weird.
Like what does that even mean?
Because a lot of these shows are
scripted.
Yeah.
They have these loose scenarios and then
they go in a script them and they redo
things.
The reshoot things.
It's not reality.
It's like shitty acting with people that
are not trained and they're edited with,
uh,
people talk in front of the camera.
Like I didn't know what Mo was thinking.
I was crazy.
And they got you.
Was like,
I told Joe What we're going to do.
No advanced,
no shit.
And then it's like conflict,
like the Kardashians.
I mean,
if they've got it down to a science,
a science of more ronic television
viewing,
right?
Greg,
if you could just sit there,
slack,
jawed,
uh,
they'll keep you locked in,
they'll keep you locked in the Ed.
They're good at it,
edits,
they'll show you their tits and boom,
you cut to commercial in there.
Right.
That's reality TV with what you guys
were doing is more documentary
television.
Yeah,
it is.
And it's not saying that.
It's not saying that there's no aspect
of,
of the convention of television there,
of course their ears.
But we used to say like,
you know,
like Vietnam doesn't look like that,
but Vietnam
doesn't not look like that,
you know,
there is a,
there is a refinement in a manipulation
in what we're doing because we're
choosing these locations are choosing to
talk to this person.
We're choosing to shoot it in a certain
way.
That's beautiful.
Where adding light,
you know,
it's not exactly the way reality is,
but there's a threshold,
there's a line which you don't cross.
And that line is,
is it a morally and ethically
established line by Tony and by the crew
that says like there's,
there's a place at which it becomes
unfair.
The manipulation of reality becomes a
manipulation.
Um,
that is now become unfair to the people
who are viewing this.
The people who are there,
you know,
we're,
we've become selfserving,
you know,
and that's the line that we chose never
to cross.
You know,
we can make it beautiful,
we can refine it down,
you know,
we can edit it,
we can make a compelling show,
but it has to,
it has to exist within,
under this,
within this certain threshold or else,
you know,
what the fuck are we doing know it must
be a small percentage of people in the
business that have that ethic incredibly
small and it's incredibly powerful to
have people.
I'm backing you that believe in that
and,
and super rare.
I mean,
you know,
we talk about in the film industry
today,
how rare it is to have true artur final
cut directors,
you know,
left.
There's only a handful of them,
you know,
largely the studios have taken over that
control will equally in the television
industry.
It's,
it's that rare to have people that have
the kind of power and control to have
the luxury of saying,
you know,
hey listen,
I have guidelines here and we're not
going to cross them.
You know,
and,
and have people be like,
great,
go,
go make it,
you know,
and we were able to do that.
Yeah.
It seems like netflix would be a really
good place for something like that.
Seems like Netflix will be a really good
place for a lot of things.
It seems like that's the,
that's the best place for like real
freedom.
Yeah.
Well I know how much is real fried when
they're giving you money.
Anytime someone's given you money,
there's always like,
you got to get the real way to deal.
It'd be like to produce it yourself,
but in the end is CNN was the best place
to do that,
you know,
and they really did back us up and they
really backed up Tony and that
philosophy and they completely
implicitly understood what we were
talking about when we said,
well we can't do that now.
It was jeff soccer.
Was it his idea?
You know,
again,
I don't know how the deal came about.
I assume so because I think it came,
it came in just after that transfer of
power.
So did they,
did he have other places where he's
thinking about taking it?
Started?
CNN again?
I don't know man.
I don't know.
I mean,
you know,
it was a really successful show in its
own right at that point.
So I'm sure it would have gone
somewhere,
but that was,
I assume it was Jeff Zucker who brought
it in and that was like such a brilliant
moves,
like a perfect marriage,
you know?
Perfect marriage,
the perfect move for CNN,
like perfect move for us.
Yeah.
I thought it was interesting when they
were taking a chance on these unscripted
television shows.
These,
these non news show.
Yeah.
Have,
you've seen the united shades of
America?
He's all bell and he's great.
He's the best.
He's a super,
super nice guy.
Yeah.
I did an episode with him in Kenya with
Tony,
um,
which will be the premier of this
upcoming season.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
so how many episodes have you guys done
that haven't aired yet?
Well,
I think we'll have seven in this next
season.
That's the only one,
um,
of those seven that was actually
completed with Tony's narration
narration,
the rest of them are uncomplete and in
that respect,
and again,
we've been kind of fighting through
editing those over the last few months
and,
and trying to figure out ways to,
you know,
to do this without completely gutting,
the,
the method of making this show.
So wow.
Um,
and then there's a couple of specials in
there like,
you know,
talking to the crew and stuff like that,
so it's going to be a pretty profound
see isn't.
So um,
once you're done with that,
you just start looking at new projects
and different things to do.
And I have
couple like assignments already,
some projects I'm like pretty excited
about,
you know,
um,
I just don't know that they've
officially been announced yet.
So,
uh,
you know,
but there's good stuff out there and
there's,
you know,
it.
One Nice thing in all of this incredibly
difficult time has a lot of people have
come to us and said like,
listen,
when we wrote,
we always believed in what you guys did
and we'd like you to continue doing it.
And here's a project we have the we
think,
you know,
so hopefully we can continue to make
things in the same kind of,
you know,
it looks like we can.
Well,
it seems like
the success of the show and then the
infectuous enthusiasm that Tony had and
that,
you know,
so many people are fans of the show had
for that style of television.
It's just gonna lead to more,
more people taking more chances and
doing things like that.
I hope so.
You know?
Um,
I think so.
I think it's getting better,
you know,
um,
there will never be another Tony you
won't find that,
you know,
and I think that's something that
people will have to be aware of going
forward.
You're not going to copy that,
right?
He's Tony and that's what you saw,
Gordon Ramsey,
they announced some show with him
traveling and people immediately just
start shitting all over him.
Yeah,
but he's really from everything I
understand.
It was like,
just like a really good guy.
You know what the problem is?
The way you phrase himself on the show,
the kitchen nightmares.
She turns in like an asshole
and yells at people that are intimidated
by him and that's his shtick,
honestly.
Just this,
this TV shtick.
Yeah.
As far as I know.
I don't know.
Yeah,
it seemed like a real nice guy.
Yeah.
I might Guy Fieri too.
He was nice guy.
Just got crazy.
You know,
Guy Fieri relentlessly shit out.
I'm
constantly Jews.
But he shits on everybody.
Did he show up Martha Raye to.
I don't know.
Yeah,
maybe.
I think maybe right?
Uh,
he would,
he would pull that trigger all the time.
Dude.
He would always make fun of his
Lamborghini and I'm like,
I'm Kinda like a Lamborghini,
like what are you talking about?
One of those things you're not supposed
to have,
right?
Like you could have some cool cars like
our member when he did the show with the
Queens of the Stone Age,
Josh home and uh,
one of the guys had a 69 Camaro shot.
That was a bad car.
Yeah.
But that's an okay to have bad ass car
because it's a classic because it's got
style points.
Totally.
But I would suggest to Tony that he
might want to pick up the Lamborghini
because the traction control
a big problems and big problems when the
Camaro.
No,
I'm sure as most people would have to
learn how to drive one of those.
That was hot rod,
man.
The thing was sick.
Okay.
But listen brother,
I'm glad we did this.
We reached out.
We decided to get together and talk,
give a lot of people insight to what it
was like to work with one of my heroes.
Yeah,
me too.
Alright.
Definitely my hero.
All right.
Thanks brother.
Thanks.
Appreciate it,
man.
Thank you.